وفي حي بيت حنينا شمال القدس المحتله على
مرمى حجر من مكان العمليه التي جرت في
مستوطنه النبي يعقوب هنا المنفذ دخل من
هذه المنطقه ااه تماما تجاه المستوطنه وصل
الى المنطقه
القريبه وفتح النار عمليا بعد ان ترجع من
السياره على مستوطنين قتل على الاقل
ثمانيه واصاب اخرين ومن ثم حاول العوده
الى حي بيت حنينا الى المنطقه العربيه
يمكن ان نرى السياره ما تزال مركونه بعد
ان اشتبك هناك مع قوات من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه التي صارعت الى اغلاق المكان
الذي تحول الى محج للسياسيين بنيامين
نتنياهو وصل وكذا ايضا وزير الامن همم
القومي الاسرائيلي المتطرف هناك اجراءات
امنيه اسرائيليه صارمه همم اتخذت في القدس
الشرقيه المحتله ايضا في الضفه الغربيه
خشيه من ان تستمر العمليات الفرديه كالتي
تمت في هذه المنطقه ان تكون هناك موجه
علما ان لا قبل تقريبا لاسرائيل لوقف هذه
العمليات لانها لا تملك معلومات
استخباراتيه بشانها عاده زياد حلبي
العربيه بيت حنينا شمال القدس المحتله